how's it going dressed my name is Pippa
welcome to just stands for there's some
new DLC came out with Gangnam style and
I don't know I wanted to try it
no look at that
no no no I can't even find the [ __ ]
sign and then na na na yes
yeah we got us dance what's up alright
here we got this what the hell is this
well my god I'm starving
I can't [ __ ] do this I'm sad
Nachi no time work time is high hey
Ritchie
welcome to this time rub this down walk
walk walk my beauty stuff the dyeing
brush ready now they can check down into
John and Allie okay I'm gonna start
Liberty start achievement [ __ ] beauty
style go medium we didn't know a baby
big no-no can we no no sad aw [ __ ] sexy
pair over there the [ __ ] is this anyway
I mad at all of us I'll be cheated a
couple of time first dad's every company
time all right
I guess I have to do another one because
that's way too short
all right that's a good song right there
I just [ __ ] me I'm too tired to dance I
don't have the skills
hey this is none what that [ __ ] am i
doing oh hey I'm really trying here in
case you're wondering hey
I think I can I made you burn D with
more than I'm improvising and [ __ ]
perfect but baby that's only perfect I
spent
if the other song wasn't gay enough
perfect Soviet secure don't know what
for you're turning heads when you walk
through
oh don't be makeup what the [ __ ] is this
then uh uh uh every wooden head against
me we don't know you should come you got
a claw your turn my right time 35 I know
the legs I'm still got this I press I
gotta have this upset I [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
yes there where did you flip your hair
gets me overwhelmed and the Chi Minh
magenta oh that's not so many
okay [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] it I say [ __ ] this game [ __ ]
everyone done [ __ ] done brofist
that's it
bigger ring [ __ ] [ __ ]
why do I know so
John Tanner and
Superman get the [ __ ] out of here